all right Donny yes hello Donny uh
where'd you grow up where are you from
originally I'm from Santa Monica
California
tell me about your family growing up uh
my fat come from a broken home um I was
raised by my mother grandmother
um
I have four
sisters and one half brother
and uh we were all born and raised there
in California
uh how would you describe your childhood
my childhood was good actually uh I
remember my mom taking me to Lovins in
1969.
you know and uh I wish I was older you
know so I couldn't experience it more
than I did but it was fun you know it
was like what did you see oh I
remembered all the girls all the hippies
all the girls they uh they all loved and
adore me and and I was like six years
old at the time and we're at MacArthur
Park you know listening to some rock
band but on a Sunday
and they used to put flowers little
carnations made a little bowl over for
my head and they used to put on top of
my hat you know so and I sat there enjoy
the music rock out with everybody else
you know it's good times I just wish I
was older
you go through uh High School yes I went
to uh Santa Monica High School and then
I got transferred later on to Aviation
High School in Redondo Beach which is no
longer there it was right there on
Aviation in Manhattan Beach Boulevard
you start getting in trouble at some
point
uh yes I start getting in trouble
probably around 14
15 16.
I was doing drugs
because years earlier I was child
molested as a child
and so I I went to court and testify
against the individual
and uh
I was promised counseling and therapy at
the End by the District Attorney's
office
and at the end of the trial I received
nothing
so I had a lot of pain shame and guilt
built up inside me
and the only way I knew how to get rid
of it was smoking weed or drinking it
and so that's what I would do I would
numb that feeling for you know for a
minute
you know a couple hours okay and then
once that Hive wear it off
the pain came back
you know uh I no longer cared about
myself I did not care about other people
you know because I was deeply scarred
and hurt inside you know
and uh
one thing led to another I was doing
burglaries uh in and out of juvenile
Halls
uh I went to a a camp called camp affler
ball in 1979
I was there for about six months and I
finally decide to leave Escape AWOL so I
a walled me and another guy we walked
all the way from San San Dimas where the
place was located at all the way to
Pomona took us a couple of hours but we
got out stayed out for approximately six
months
and then I picked up a a burglary
because once again I was doing
burglaries to support my drug habit at
the time to numb away the pain that I
had Within
okay and uh so I I go and they send me
to another Camp it's Camp Gonzalez up on
Los virginas Road up in Malibu Canyon
right above Pepperdine
uh I was there until I was about
9 19 years old I got out about two weeks
after my 19th birthday and uh got out
stayed out for a little bit was working
uh in 83 I was working for McDonald's in
Pizza Hut doing good
uh and then I start uh selling Coke
for extra money basically
and uh
so one thing led to another I I quit my
job I'm now full-time selling drugs
because I'm making good money I'm making
lots of money you know I got new cars I
I got everything I want I got a girl I
got a couple of girlfriends
you know
um
one night uh while I was at work I my
girlfriend was watching the place at the
time
that I was with Jennifer is her name
um
I went to work came home I seen all
these ambulance cop cars in the front
you know so automatically I'm thinking
oh [__] something happened to Jennifer
and I see them Wheeling my girlfriend on
a stretcher
so I I still don't know what's going on
so I get in my car I follow the
ambulance back to the hospital where
they take her to here at St John's in
Santa Monica
I get there I finally get to see my girl
after on sitting there maybe two hours
as they were operating on her she
suffered a broken jaw broken cheekbone
so when I was able to go in and talk to
her a few hours later
she told me what happened
my best friend
while I was at work went into my
apartment with my girlfriend there
beat my girl pistol whipped her
broker jaw cheekbone asking where's the
money drugs and the safe at
after my girl Jennifer got beaten up
pretty bad
I mean uh
the guy took all the stuff
she tells me who this person was I know
exactly who it was
so I went home grabbed my gun
357 Magnum and a 22.
I go right over to his place I knock on
the door first thing I do I shoot him in
his kneecaps
okay I'm mad at the fact that not over
the dope or the money that can be
replaced but when you go in my apartment
and you assault my girlfriend and break
her jaw and her cheekbone I have a
problem with that sorry
and so after shooting them in the
kneecaps he starts begging for his life
because he knows I'm going to kill him
and that's what exactly I did I shot him
in the head and killed him Point Blank
did I feel any remorse at that time of
course not no I seen it as getting even
you know because of what he did of my
girlfriend that wasn't cool you know
what I mean if he would have simply just
asked for the drugs and money my
girlfriend would have gave it to him
and so I ended up getting arrested for
that crime
uh we were trying to say it was
self-defense but
because I left my apartment if
let's say this if I would have came home
and the guy was still in my apartment
then I had a legal right of killing them
right there on the spot
but because I left my house with a gun
premeditated and go over to his place
it's now murder first degree
because it was pre-planned
and so I ended up with a 25 to life
sentence
back in 1985 in the California
Department of Corrections
I recently got out on April 12
2023 after going to the parole board
three separate times
I was finally given a date
and this is where I'm at today in Los
Angeles
huh how long ago did you get out I just
got out April 12th oh so you're fresh
out yes I just got out almost two months
ago you know you don't seem
institutionalized no a lot of people
they trip on that they they they because
they a lot of people you got to be
strong-minded because a lot of people go
to prison they allow the system in the
prison system to change who they are as
an individual
I refuse I went in there refusing to
allow that to happen to me because I
seen what it did to other people so I
did not let the system break me
I broke the system
uh
for a lot of years I
I took the blame of everything right I
was I was the guilty victim I felt
until I came to an understanding of
giving forgiveness to the very person
who molested me as a child
uh by doing that today I'm cleaning
sober I'm being sober for over 20 years
now
and I'm able to move forward in life
and become a better person
uh starting next month in July I'm going
to college I'm going to be a drug
counselor
forgiving your I'm no it's my way of
giving back to society but forget
forgiving the person who uh oh yeah for
molesting me yes yes that's impressive
yes I had to do that because without
without doing that
then I would never move forward in life
you don't hear that a lot but it's true
that's how I you know I see it it worked
for me you've seen very much at peace
with the whole situation I have to be I
have to be if I'm not at peace
then my life is I need structure in my
life because I've been under structure
all my life in the prison system so I
need that out here too so I can succeed
because without structure I don't know
how to live and we're you're staying
here in skid row now I'm still staying
right here on 6th and San Pedro at the
at the uh Weingart yeah so you're you're
surrounded by drugs you're not tempted
no the thought of even using doesn't
even register in my mind it's all around
me you're absolutely right and the first
thing I ask myself is why would the
California Department of parole send me
here see I'm originally from the West
Side Santa Monica
and so I came to the conclusion that the
reason why they have me here is so every
day when I walk out of this bill it I
can see what's around me and that tells
me right there if I start using drugs or
drink it either or
I can be right here where they're at so
it's a reality check for me that's how
I'm looking at it and that's how I'm
taking it and it's working
for you
what was it what was the darkest part of
your stay in prison
oh wow uh there's a few of them but uh
probably one of them was being in a ride
in pelican-based State Prison
uh
in the year 2000
I was uh I was working at the time I was
working in the kitchen morning crew
and they had a big Riot between the
Serranos which is the Southerns and your
blacks
and
One inmate 18 year old kid got shot
killed shot in the head by the gun Tower
and his body like was like right here
and then on this side of the body you
had uh
blacks and then on this side of the body
as they're trying to get them over here
he's dead uh the Serranos
uh
very scary very very scary
um
I didn't think I would make it
that day
there's so much chaos going around
but I was like lucky I survived it
uh I don't know how I did it but I did
it you know uh
I didn't want to participate in it
you know I mean and because I was white
I didn't have to now if I was Sereno or
Mexican then you would have to you know
because if you don't participate then
uh you can get hurt badly by your people
for not participating in a riot against
another race
yeah
if you had your life to live all over
again what would you have done
differently
not be so friendly to strangers I don't
know
which led to me being molested in the
first place and Trust
because I had a lot of trust
and love within my heart
and I was taking advantage of it
and because of that I suffered many
years of being out of the institutions I
got over 40 years in the institutions
you know
and so that right there was the biggest
part
that trust trust in others
basically I wouldn't have that anymore
yeah
because of what occurred to me as a
child that was taken was it a family
friend or uh actually it was a teacher
my third grade teacher oh wow yeah and
Santa Monica Unified School District
uh
yeah that's that's how it happened he
got caught yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
got caught prosecuted I had to go to
court testify I mean Junior High School
yeah I mean Junior High School I think I
was in seventh grade it was 1975.
and uh
yeah that was that was a big thing to do
I mean I was in open court there's
people in the courtroom I did not know
that I had to sit up there and give him
my testimony
and being as young as I was you know and
there were several times when I actually
broke down in tears on the stand
given my testimony
because of the hurt the pain
so we're given recess
then we continue on
you know and uh
never got the counseling or therapy they
promised me
that's what that's another big what if I
heard you come about
forgiving him
uh oh wow that took a lot of work on my
behalf I had to take a lot of self-help
groups well in prison
and I'm glad I took them
because I was able to dig deep within
myself find out where the core of all
this transpired from
you know and this goes all the way back
to when I was a child just observing and
hearing my mother
or you know or or or my stepfather
beating her you know uh so a lot of that
had a play some part you know and me
being who I am today
what's your biggest fear now
my biggest fear is going back to prison
with another life sentence
because I know if that ever happens I'll
never get out
I was lucky to get out this time
after serving 38 years
um
so I obey the laws
I do not jaywalk
and I'm not even thinking about doing
crimes I'm just trying to get my life
together it's never too late
I start college next month to be a drug
counselor
do you have kids none never been married
no kids never been in love
I I don't think so I don't think I ever
been in love I really I mean I can maybe
count five girlfriends I have in my
lifetime
because majority of my life probably 70
percent of it
is been incarcerated and I'm not gay so
I don't have gay relationships with the
guys in prison so yeah today I'm single
I'm happy
uh I have female friends don't get me
wrong but uh
I don't I don't there's nobody right now
that I love no
you're so young for your age yeah yeah
I'm only going to be 60 when people call
me old I I kind of like what
you can't be serious
they say prison uh they yeah they said
that uh that I don't look 60 that uh and
that all the time I've done I'm totally
uh really humble person you know and
they they just don't understand that you
know and once again it's because I did
not allow the system to break me
I I I kept who I was inside all them
times all them dark periods you know I
kept them here you know
and uh that's why who I am today Donnie
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your life my
most important lesson I learned in my
life
is probably
don't use drugs
because
there's only two things that can happen
if you use drugs or drink
that's either death or in prison
one or the other
so my advice please
stay away
you'll be a much happier person
if you do because I had a false belief
system for many many years that I had to
get high every day to function
that's not true
but that's one of the biggest lies I
ever told myself and I still remember
that big lie you know and today I live
by it yes you can be happy every day and
not use
yeah all right Donnie thank you so much
for sure amen thank you thank you for
sharing your story yes thank you
appreciate it good luck with you the
rest of your life yeah thank you thank
you very much you got plenty of years
left oh yeah yeah that's what they say I
don't want to get too old
[Laughter]